in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Tom and
Sharon are with us hey guys how are ya
fine
welcome welcome nowhere do you two live
in Anderson Indiana just north of
Anderson Alexandra's very cool and
you're here to do your debt-free screen
yes we are and how much have you paid
off we've paid off a hundred and
thirty-eight thousand I love it and cash
flowed seventy thousand during that time
cool for what well we had to upgrade our
cars after we paid off our consumer debt
and we paid cash for cars and a sunroom
and I finished my college education okay
and then did you get is this the house
as well as been paid out so then you so
you finish the consumer picked up a
couple of these I adds a ninja needed to
do and then went knock the house off
absolutely how long did this take it
took just ten years ten years excellent
making what kind of money during that
time well we started around seventy four
thousand and I stepped out of the
traditional marketplace as a registered
nurse and began my own business mm-hmm
and now we're over a hundred thousand
I'm not sure exactly because our
accountant hasn't got back with us yet I
love it when a plan comes together
good for you way to go so ten years ago
something happened after all those years
of marriage and you said all right we're
gonna stop doing it the normal way we're
gonna get rid of the consumer debt we're
gonna pay cash for stuff and then we're
gonna pay off our house what happened
well I like to listen to talk radio and
I normally listen to like Bruce Williams
or something like yeah but this guy on
the radio was saying something different
but I worked in a delivery truck and I
couldn't listen to the radio unless I
was driving mm-hmm the other guy could
listen to it so when I got to drive I'd
listen to talk radio and I started
listening to Dave Ramsey oh my gosh so
you came home with all these crazy ideas
and said Sharon we're gonna get out of
debt and what did Sharon say well I've
had many crazy ideas we'd come home from
the mission field in in Oh two
mm-hmm and we had no car no jobs no
houses no house nothing and we moved
into my older brother's bedroom and in
that matter of fact the first week my
daughter moved in with us he lifts left
on the bed and I slept on the floor and
that's where we started in otwo Wow and
here you sit completely debt-free with
the house paid for and everything right
that's absolutely amazing so Sharon he
comes in starts spouting all this stuff
he's hearing on the radio and he says
he's got a scheme or two in the past
what did what did you say
well I went and bought him the book oh
and we had taken our oldest grandson
Isaac to California to visit my mom and
he read the book on the way to
California on the plane and then he just
started talking about what was going on
and I started listening and I got behind
my man there you go just like that I
love it that's fun that's fun so what
was the hardest part of this for you two
I think the budget is obviously the
answer to most of the solutions but I
had started taking all the old
appliances from the company I was
working for Lowe's and I was bringing
home cleaning up Washington and
reselling them you know I had created a
nice little my own little savings
account mm-hmm I had to give up my
little savings account to start the plan
okay all right and then she became the
one running the not running the budget
but following through with the plan okay
so you became you became the one that
executed the details insurance Ashley
the hardest initial thing for me was
cutting up that credit card you know 40
years of marriage we had lived on a
credit card or at least had the security
of a credit card so initially for me it
was like he wanted to and I did not I it
was the security net for me and that was
initially the hardest thing and then
eventually I'm just following the plan
and keeping disciplines and not getting
sloppy after we had paid off our
consumer debt probably within the first
two years
and then just staying at the task you
know in keeping disciplined that was
probably the hardest and finally last
January I said that is it this mortgage
has got to go and we just started just
piling the money in I love it that's
fine so you brought a bunch a family
with we so what's what's the story why
is the entire gang here to celebrate
this is a legacy days everything in our
life has been spiritual from from when
we went to the mission field today and
it's much more than about us it is about
our family and leaving a legacy of
divine influence in their life
and that is just vitally important to us
everything that we say everything that
we do that we leave an influence for our
kids so how much influence is all of
this been are they doing this stuff some
and some not okay thus they're here
alright so hopefully something will be
breathed in out of Dorothy's kitchen in
there yeah it's fun
well very cool I'm sure they're proud of
you guys they've watched mom and dad
toil through some stuff here and knocked
some things out and it's it's cool that
they're here to support you in this very
very neat I love it I love it can I say
that when she decided to come out of the
workplace we got your entree leadership
book yes and we sat down and read it
together before we started the business
that she's in very cool very successful
my daughter's part of my business as
another to art to other nurses yeah I
don't know it's just been a blessing for
me to walk away fault from full time and
make just as much money or more at home
doing what I do as registered nurse was
a blessing yeah yeah I I want you and
one of them to come with you to the
business boutique event in either
Phoenix or Dallas as my guest we're
going to give you two tickets you can
make your way down there we'll pay you
they should be there very fine I forgot
one other thing I accepted a pastor to
mm-hm and then I worked full-time as a
truck driver
there you go my kind of pastor it's good
stuff you guys are incredible it's fun
talking to you you're rock stars how
long you been married 40 years have you
ever been debt-free no as of January 4th
it became debt-free forever and I took
my two twin granddaughters with me to
the bank to pay off our mortgage and do
you know the teller wanted me to take
out a loan I said are you kidding me the
bank I might shoot you yeah all right
here we go Tom and Sharon from Anderson
Indiana 208 thousand dollars cash flow
that includes 138 thousand dollars worth
of debt housing everything in 10 years
making 74 up to a hundred count it down
let's hear a debt free scream to God be
the glory
3 2 1
and the whole cheering section goes
crazy I love it you guys are fun well
that's exactly as it should be you know
you cannot change your life in any area
of your life whether it's your spiritual
walk whether it's your money getting
your act together like they did whether
it's deciding to lose weight and get
your physique under control whether it's
impacting your marriage or your
parenting you cannot change your life
without automatically impacting those
that are in your life because people are
always watching and they're always
taking their cues sometimes you're a
distant mentor sometimes in the past
I've been so bad at something that was
an anti mentor meaning they would look
at me and figure out what not to do
right but when you do good stuff like
Tom and Sharon are doing it rubs off
rubs off on the people you love and the
people that respect you and the people
that are watching and that includes
family it's very very cool stuff
absolutely fun boom
I love it this is how it's done right
here baby and you're next you yeah I'm
talking to you mm-hmm
this is the Dave Ramsey chef hey you
guys Rachael Cruz here hope you are
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right it's kind of
better
save room to channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you